انا من عمان اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي سياده اللواء يبدو
ان هناك اجماعا اذا ان سقوط بخموت سريعا
سيحدث وهو مساله وقت فقط
يعني لا اتصور ذلك يعني يمكن ان ياخذ فتره
لانه بعد ثمن اشهر استطاعوا ان يصلوا الى
الجزء الشرقي منها الى ضفاف نهر
وبالتالي الجزء الاكبر من المدينه لا يزال
يقع خلف هذا النهر يضاف الى ذلك التحول
الرئيسي في الموقف الاوكراني قبل عده ايام
تحدثت نائب وزير الدفاع وقالت تم ايكال
اتخاذ القرار الى القاده العسكريين حول
بالامس اجتماع الرئيسكي وقائد الجيش
تمخض عن ضروره الدفاع وكلمه الدفاع هنا
توظف في بعدين اولا معركه استنزاف مضنيه
مكلفه
تحقق احد امرين الامر الاول
حتى في حال سقوطها يكون قد تم احداث
اضرار وخسائر كبيره في القوه البشريه
ومعدات القتال
تقلل من احتمالات نجاح هذه القوات في
تطويرها هجماتها باتجاه اسلام
اما الهدف الاكبر ان تستمر هذه المعركه
ريثما يتم اعداد القوات الكافيه لشن هجمات
معاكسه في بدايه الشهر القادم وهذا يعتمد
على مجموعه من العوامل اهمها وصول المعدات
اذا نحن نقول ملوش النظر عسكريه ان باخمت
ستسقط لكن السؤال متى وما هو الثمن وما هي
التداعيات الناتجه عن السقوط على طرفي
الصراع نعم ولكن يعني باخمت اوكرانيه
ستسقط في ايدي الروس ما افهمه من كلامك
وكان
انتصار الروس في معركه كهذه
هو بمثابه انتصار بطعم الخساره كما احيانا
يقال في كره القدم
يا سيدي هي الان فيما يتعلق بمعركه باخموت
الان بعد من بعد ثمانيه اشهر من القتال
دفع فاتوره باهظه من قبل الجيش الروسي ومن
قبل قوات فاجنر
وتباينه التقارير حول الاعداد الجانب
الاوكراني يتحدث في بعض الايام عن اكثر من
الف قتيل الجانب الروسي يتحدث عن 500 الى
700 قتيل اذا هي معركه مكلفه للجانبين لكن
انا كقراءتي لهذه المعركه اقول ان الجانب
الاوكراني يتمسك بها لتحقيق احد امرين كما
قلت اما الانهاك التام
ومنع القوات من تطوير يعني جعل
نقطه ارتكاز وقاعده انطلاق للمعارك
اللاحقه الى
وبالتالي يمكن احكام سيطره على
بالكامل اما الامر الاخر ان تتمكن من
الدفاع والاستمرار بالدفاع وهذا ما اشر له
الرئيس زيلينسكي حريثما يتم اعداد قوه
كافيه لشن هجمات معاكسه من اتجاهات مختلفه
تجبر القوات الروسيه وفاقنار على الانسحاب
لكن كلا الامرين له مرتكزات يتحقق بتوفر
المرتكزات المعطيات الحاليه الحديث عن 18
دبابه الحديث عن اربع دبابات الى غير ذلك
هذا لا يمكن الجانب الاوكراني من شن هجوم
الربيع بالصوره التي يتحدث عنها شكرا شكرا
جزيلا لك اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي من عمان